the lost ones the coolest ones okay I'm
joking it's not actually gonna happen
it's called the air coalition heuristic
it is legitimately about ants okay let's
show you I'm here do it I'm watching it
I don't know
obviously everyone okay all right so
he's the way it works right sorry I
asked for my sake but okay no cogent
place for a second it's they do this
kind of thing I want you to now stop
thinking about this as a traveling
salesman at cities I want you to think
about this as a map with food sources
pundits that pants are off okay and
they're gonna colonize wherever they
find food okay now clearly just like
with the salesman it is in the interest
of the ants to have the most efficient
path through but he's the crazy thing
okay how have we gone about doing
Enza with a lot of intelligence okay
like we've brought about this hard we
have these like sophisticated techniques
for doing this what techniques are there
it's got an elastic they don't have
anything in terms of intellect I'll tell
you what they do have though yes yes
well what specifically I hope is right
you can look it up and tell me if a
little more specifically their
pheromones now just get this okay what
this what we're about to show you what I
got to show you is what we call emergent
behavior maybe I'll write that down for
you emergent behavior it's this idea of
things that are not being organized from
like so top structure being imposed on
them but just by virtue of each
and the things that are driving this a
baby are emerges out of all the
individuals working together okay
now this really is a kid if you don't
know if pheromones are basically just
the chemical right and ants can stuff
that can sense it
okay now all its are going to do what
guides them is that they will follow
hell literally follow their noses okay
so what they'll do is wherever they can
sense the pheromone they will follow
that part now there are particular
answer they have the job of giving off
pheromone okay um like scout scout ants
but all and students okay so here's the
way works let's pick a start point so
here's our start point from here do they
know where the food is and the answer is
no they do not
okay so simply what the Scout parties do
is they just go like random directions
and they just go until they like find
something find something find something
now here's the thing right they just
they just Fanning up they're also going
on all these other directions as well
but I don't need to clear my diagram
what happens is just imagine what
happens or let's go for this one what
happens when they find this food okay so
they find the food they found food so
they're going to bring it back to their
colony right now remember these ads
they're traveling as they go they are
leaving forever behind them okay so as
they travel and then travel back they've
made twice as much memory as an ant
that's gone to another place that's like
the same distance but there's nothing
there okay because once they've gone if
they haven't come back and they didn't
need to come back they didn't find it so
there is but the point is now if I'm in
you and here right and unlike which way
do I go
well I'm gonna follow my nose and there
is twice as much caramel on this pod as
this one so I'm gonna take this part
does that make sense so now that's one
leg up right obviously where this food
there's gonna be more positive because
they're going everywhere right and then
we prune off the places where there's no
food but even better I said there's
gonna be pheromones
right now just look at this spot here
see that's what their now this spot here
is closer than the first one I found do
you see that okay now because is closer
when they go back it doesn't take them
as long right they can do it faster
which means that for example suppose
this leg is not but suppose it was half
the length of this one over here okay
and let's say it takes an hour to go
from here to let's label these things
going from A to B and then back that
takes an hour okay now because this is
half the distance right in that same
hour what's going to happen for the
answer that go from D to C it's half the
distance right they're gonna go there
and then back and then in that same time
they go there and back again so now
there's four times as much fairer on
this path because it's closed up do you
see how such a simple mechanism finds
the most efficient path okay
because automatically the parts that are
closest are gonna be laden with the most
fair amount and that's what the ads will
follow and the same thing will happen
when they go here you rather than here
or here rather than over there right
they still gonna find stuff and bring it
back but this path will be weak and this
one will be very strong so it's gonna
become like an ant Highway okay by
virtue of this simple mechanism okay
now the cool thing is messengers like
this is ingenious right they called this
by the way this has a proper term in
engineering they call this biomimicry
when we see a design that you know has
been produced at in nature and it's
really really good at what it does right
we try to imitate them like we try to
imitate living systems okay that's
exactly right
there's just you can just order none
other so many engineers right yeah yeah
it's like nearest neighbor but nearest
neighbor we'll just go straight to one
right this is actually going to create
this creates a rather more complicated
Network right I'm awesome
because what will happen is it will it
will create this path that it'll be
stronger it will create this part that
moves from God but it won't destroy
either of these parts
where's the nearest day but just takes
the first one okay over time just
imagine right suppose now someone wants
to go from here all the way over to here
okay now if you just went the nearest
neighbor technique right there will only
ever be one part okay but over time it
may actually happen that there's a
different network of paths a bit like
you know if you got parents they like
driving between the same point same two
points over ever again right they
quickly work out because of my traffic
and time of day are this actually it's
not the closest by a distance right but
you know this point might have less
traffic or this point might have less
terrain or something like that which
isn't as obvious just on this skid okay
so you're right has a same kind of idea
is more sophisticated now much more
clever because it's awesome